all right it's 2:00 o'clock do you know
where your children are Frank where are
your children okay
so as you all know we're going to start
I welcome to chess for knights try not
to sit in front of the camera you know
unless you know you're pretty like me
then okay we're going to look at two
positions today and then we're going to
talk about the rules raise your hand not
you at home
raise your heat put your hand down raise
your hand the people at home raise their
hand raise your hand if you're playing
in the tournament today at 2:30
the views playing Danny you're playing
Frank good job okay in the tournament
you have to play touch move touch your
piece you have to move it so they'll be
touching everything go here indeed if
you say indeed enough we can you can
play in the London chess classic later
okay now there are two positions I want
to show you and they're very complicated
but your chest for Knights right so you
guys are so smart your brains are going
to explode okay and we're going we're
going to keep that to a minimum today
now this was a game between the Chinese
players Engler in one of the top five
players in China possibly top three
possibly top one Aviv what's your
opinion you have somewhere like that
no Lee Chow is pretty good okay the Matt
Larson things Dingling will win vikon's
a so that's cuz he's pretty good because
he magnus carlsen playing alright and
black is Michael Adams the oldest player
to ever play chess he's still younger
than me okay I met Michael Adams before
chess existed okay I met him in 1986
were you at that tournament why not you
were there I saw you there yeah I think
you got like four out of nine yeah okay
that maybe you got three and a half all
right so Michael Adams is black and he's
playing Dingley rin whose turn is it
yeah
ah this is the two o'clock class nice
okay it's White's turn because white is
in check now not only is he in check
he's in a skewer okay
you see what I'm saying over here so
like if King e4 then he'll lose his
Knight
okay so white played what move yes King
c6 is a good move he played a better
move but your move is second best so
you're like the second best player who's
the second best player see there's
Carlsen than me was me you King e5 I
want a lot of silver medals in chess but
usually my opponent's won the gold and
then that was it
King e5 okay now uh black played ninety
eight the losing move ah right
okay so let's have a look at the normal
move yeah Road takes a three check did
at Michael item see that was possible of
course then he thought ding luring would
play King f6 threatening everything too
many threats like rook f7 Shaq Knight f7
and rook e8 with me okay turns out black
can draw here but Michael Adams didn't
see the drawing move cuz it was too hard
he's rated 2750 okay that's like your
ratings if we added them all up and
that's because of eve's here otherwise
you need a lot of trouble okay what's
the drawing move for black it's the
craziest move ever
I'll give you a hint it stops me and it
stops rook takes pawn bathrooms over
there you but I put it right to him
what's the problem
90 it is okay but the computer says it
loses so it's not totally okay okay but
but 98 is that's a move but it doesn't
quite work there's a crazy move if it
was an easy move I wouldn't ask you I
would ask the one o'clock class but it's
a 2 o'clock class that's hard it's so
hard at 2700 couldn't find it it's
pretty hard
anyone Bueller Martin while King to g8
is a move but it still loses because
your F pawns hanging and check I mean it
doesn't get made it in one but it still
loses this move is so crazy it just
might work
someday Aviv will solve it you 97 is
correct and probably Michael Adams
didn't do this because he didn't see
Knights e7 he was like Knights e7 my
Knights hanging now 97 does stop me you
agree because Knight takes rook right
and after rook takes we play rook check
forking the knight of the King okay and
the computer says this is a draw because
it's a draw right okay but 97 is a crazy
move he didn't see that okay
instead he played four tricks you know
why the tricks didn't work wow that was
a good setup good job you're hired
because tricks are for kids a good job
he knew that too he's been working on
that all night he looked to the mirror
and said why why okay Arjen what were
you going to say Michael Adams played
ninety eight okay now that's the losing
move and Ziggler ends like hey I'm the
best player I should win I'm winning
right that's a good idea right okay so
Dean wearing has two moves that look
good rook d7 and rook to a8 which one
did he play he played the better one we
could vote should we vote
all right what are you're voting for a a
right all right what do you yeah what
are you voting for all right who says he
played rook a a the green move and who
says he played rook d7 the red move
how about and I think the abstentions
have it okay but we don't we didn't have
a quorum so we'll have to wait a few
minutes right okay and did you bring
your taxes with you anyone why not did
you get a w-9 terrible okay white played
rugby seven the only winning move
because it does three things it attacks
the knight it defends this Knight and it
attacks this pawn on f7 also King e7 is
slightly illegal that's that's so bad
the one o'clock class is like no that's
the across the street class they're like
King e7 even more popular was King e8
for the across the street class okay so
Michael Adams who's losing now played
like a hundred tricks in a row okay
did Engler in far fall for those tricks
no the last one was really good though
the last trick was so good the arbiters
like okay draw that was a great trick is
that what happened now okay so Michael
Adams played rook takes III check now
when I was having a chess lesson with
Matt Larson and the computer said rook
takes c3 is a draw at night d8 loses
Matt Larson was like oh yeah he'll play
rook takes c3 Michael Adams is great
that he played ninety eight we went off
again so the point is with this position
and the next one the game should have
been a draw but that doesn't mean every
move draws that means if you play
perfect you draw most kids when they get
to an end game like this they move
really fast and then all their moves are
terrible good players like a vivre go
heme interesting think forever and then
play the perfect way okay
so we thought Michael Adams would do
that but he was tired will you guys play
chess the game takes 30 seconds right
when these guys play chess the game
takes five and a half
hours for one game okay so he's tired at
the end and he was the oldest player in
the tournament he's twice as old as his
opponent okay his opponents 20 and he's
40 except he's more than 40 all right so
he got tired and he thought he was going
to draw
he played rook check I wonder what white
did okay he played the only legal move
all right now I'm going to take your
knight and if the knight moves I'm going
to take on f7 so black plays the
trickiest move ever
until the next trick he played King g7
giving his Knight away did Engler in
take the free knight and do this because
he was cold cold invite kansai right
you've been there cold right how many of
icons days have you been to 15 nice I've
been the four maybe yeah maybe all right
so did he play rook takes tonight is
that what he did half the classes like
adds a free night okay if you had taken
the night what would Michael Adams have
done Arjen never play f6 f6
checkmate the computer agrees okay that
was tricky
now black isn't threatening checkmate
now because the knight spin the pawns
pinned
okay you can't go here because it's
illegal now this King doesn't have a lot
of squares to go to does it it has zero
that's not a lot okay you got your
calculator with you okay see if zero is
a lot it's more than like half the
numbers right okay so what did Y do so
his King could escape escaping is good
you
he played f5 now he's threatening pawn
takes rook and rook takes Knight and
there's no maid anymore okay so now it
looks like Michael Adams is going to
lose but I told he's twenty seven fifty
so he's tricky right so he played rookie
three attacking the pawn jingler in
played check
I wonder where Michael Adams would jizz
King maybe he took the pawn the one
o'clock class so that was fine okay so
what did he do
where'd the King go yes go to h7 that's
what he did and then ding Liam was very
hungry so he went yum yum yum yum yum
and took the knight now White has an
extra night you know I mean okay now
Michael Adams played a move that's so
tricky then like if a vivre was white
and if you didn't see this move he would
be scared by this move but if he would
see it so he wouldn't be scared okay
he played rookie for very tricky
confusing the class so everybody at home
is really confused there on the floor
crying right now
okay but the four year old Frank is not
confused Frank Knight takes rook
Knight takes rook let's see what the
computer has to stamp say about that
probably some crazy abbreviation that
makes no sense yeah that whoever
programmed there they should be firing
medially yeah who did that
so that's stalemate because there wasn't
room to put now of course there was
alright so that's still me because black
can't move anywhere so who wins
all right if you say white then where do
you go one o'clock class right stalemate
is its hi nobody wins unless you're
playing checkers then you're good right
playing checkers you still meet your
opponent you win but not in chess so
this would be a draw because nobody can
win it's blacks turn to move and he
can't move okay now white didn't want to
steal me black because White's up a
knight on the other hand blacks
threatening checkmate you see what I'm
saying so you don't want to get checked
way to do you so most of you would take
the rook and the game would be a draw
and some of you wouldn't take the rock
and you would lose
ding we're in found a third option where
he wins that was the best option and not
only did he win it was the only move
that wins so sometimes in chess you have
one move the draws otherwise you'll lose
and sometimes in chefs you have one move
that wins jingler in looked at his score
sheet he was keeping notation and it
said he was rated 2770 he's like oh I
should find the winning move then I'm
really high rated right well make sure
when you're playing you know look at
your score sheet don't don't do it all
right
you wrote to hae check it's true I
wouldn't lie to you okay now most of you
would take the rook but Michael Adams
did not take the rook that's why he's
2750 or whatever what did he do yeah no
he's in check yeah so he didn't do no
checkmate hmm you
cause that's half right yeah he lost
yeah probably yeah he resigned and cried
good job
the reason he resigned is this is the
only legal move and now that's not
stalemate anymore it was stalemate now
it's not
and you'll notice white has an extra
night which is very comes in handy okay
and soon white will have three extra
Queens so so a black gave up and we're
cage shakes the only move that wins if
you take the rook its stalemate and if
you want to meet you then you lose but
ding Liron let me ask you a question
when Michael Adams played rookie 4 do
you think ding Liron already saw that
and he knew he was going to play rook h8
or he was like oh no oh I have rook h8
winning that was lucky what do you think
you think he saw it before or he got
lucky you'll notice people rated 2770
are lucky all the time because because
they see stuff yeah yeah because they
see everything then when they don't see
anything then their rating is 1770 okay
you hear me talking Danny all right
Danny's like I'm 1,900 what's going on
here yeah he's furious can I help you
you have your own computer what's it's
reading okay alright tell that that game
was a nice win yesterday I'll shove in a
drop okay what a Judy cake came a 1 0 ok
now this game was played today or
yesterday it was in the challenger's
those guys are so weak who knows alright
now in the B group ok they have another
tournament the first tournament is all
the best players in the world and Vaughn
Whaley land if you didn't laugh at all
Wow the second group is very suspicious
those guys are slightly better than me
and they still put their games on the
Internet
ok although in this game why
was not better than me okay now this
game this position should be a draw just
like the last game because both sides
have the same stuff two rooks two
bishops one King and four pawns right
and most of the games in the B group one
side is up a king because they don't
play so well but in this game they both
have one King does that make sense Frank
thanks like yeah okay so here white
decided to make a mistake every move and
lose the game okay not a good idea but
White had a good excuse okay when you
play chess occasionally use a chest
timer who's done that before you use a
clock okay they were using a clock and
they didn't have much time left their
time was about to run out so they had to
move really fast okay so what white
should do is go on yum-yum-yum-yum-yum
take upon okay then everybody trades
everything they do to a draw and
everybody's happy instead white played
Bishop to G - okay well black move first
we won't talk about that so what what
White was thinking black will take and
then I'll take back somehow okay but
white learned a valuable lesson and the
lesson is when your pieces are pinned
that's not good so what it black do to
pin this bishop so the bishop couldn't
move without losing a rook losing a rook
is bad if you're taking notes Arjen
wrote to g4 now if the bishop moves
black plays rook takes rook
if the bishop doesn't move then the
bishop never moves which isn't good okay
now White's King is in trouble because
that King doesn't have a lot of squares
to go to you can't go to any of those
squares can you so if this rook went
down here at some point that King has
nowhere to go
conversely black has so many squares
with the King blacks confused that's the
safest King ever okay so not only is
White's King
trouble White's Bishop is pinned okay so
white made further bad moves because
then the game would end quickly then go
to Froyo White was very upset because
this game was played in the Netherlands
they don't have a frog under the
tournament right if they were playing
here they go to Froyo after so you've
been to the Sinquefield cup with
Nakamura and Carlsen right when their
games over they run to Froyo right he's
like yeah okay
so why you played this should takes f6
I wonder what if he was going to have
soon Froyo okay and the reason why
played Bishop f6 and also Bishop f6 is
now the king can escape okay so if
there's a check my king can walk up the
board when you're playing chess and
there's a lot of pieces on the board do
you want to walk your king up the board
no what would dire straits do they would
do the walk of life did you know the
answer all right good
okay so black played rook g3 check and
whites like no problem I saw that King
to d4
my king is safe nobody can checkmate me
okay Mike nothing wrong with my king are
these pieces defending the white king
not terrible right and black has a
bishop stopping the King upon and a
bishop stopping the King a rook stopping
the King that get Kings pretty bad okay
so what did black do in this position
two answers are acceptable because they
make equally quickly yes
d3 that's right and now I think that's
checkmate and the class is over there's
no legal moves right check me fat this
was a kid's tournament I guarantee you
most of you would say checkmate even
though it's not checked me now what is
why do Frank and all your years of chess
experience what would you do with white
right now you're too old to answer that
question are you even allowed in this
class aren't you - you're not a kid
anymore are you sixteen and a half six
and a half
that's much older than him also you were
might turn them in 1986 so I don't know
if you were six and a half so why play
king e5 right now I have a question
where can the White King move no where
is correct so this was bughouse black
would have about 37 checkmates if you
know what bug house is
yeah then every move is made you could
put a night here night here night here
Queen here rook here pawn here not
everyone was made okay but this isn't
bug house this is real life okay this
game was played yesterday and White was
born yesterday so lost okay well I only
see one move that's check do you see any
moves litter check check that must be
checkmate right why not
Wow the King takes the bishop then then
white would win why does an active King
if only black had a move so that the
King couldn't take the bishop there hold
on hold on thinking well hold I'm taking
you in the corner yeah
Ricks idiot does defend d6 unfortunately
my bishop would take you and then
there's no Froyo Martin rook to be six
same ideas Rick to da
now we're threatening checkmate and
there's a lot of good defenses for Wyatt
right lots of ways to stop it the class
is so quiet argent how do you stop me
Bishop e7 x clan I think that is X clan
alright so why didn't play Bishop e7
guess what white did Arjen White resign
this should be 7 I just take it and then
I go back and meet you so that's a very
safe King right no and these pieces are
helping his king aren't they no but look
at black blacks like Worf e+ he's got
the rook going on the bishop the rook
this Bishop all pieces are attacking
White's King what's funny about this
game just like the last game is that in
this position computer said equal should
be a draw and then white guy made it in
four moves chess is tough isn't it and
these players are rated 2,400 2,500
2,600 so when you get better at chess
and your rating is really high that you
can get made it to no no but even the
grandmasters and best players in the
world sometimes they make mistakes
especially your the end of the game
because their time is running out but if
you have time on your clock you should
think in positions like this because
there's so many pieces on the board and
white tried to trade pieces and black
said now I'm going to pin your piece
instead ok then white got greedy and got
checkmated Oh
- bad the bishops coming here with me
which I like is it's a retreat right
I like retreats you with some comment
you have a good defense f5 here
checkmate the computer said so well the
truth hurts you could also take my
bishop and then check me and chess is
hard I got I got to see me no matter
what you do or you could give all your
pieces away and then get made it also a
good option okay if you are playing in
the 230 tournament because it starts at
2:30 hopefully you've entered otherwise
my comers can put the hammer down that
you should line up and go with our
associate Danny Machuca that guy there
what's like shirt on and you can play in
the tournament
it starts at 2:30 which is in four
minutes or you could go that way on your
own I don't know